bien hay había siete candidatos buenos
días para empezar desde donde hablo con
ustedes ha habido varios candidatos que
se han retirado en una carta a la las
autoridades se han mantenido cuatro
candidatos de los cuales uno el jefe del
tribunal supremo parte que goza del
apoyo del líder supremo de la revolución
y pareciera que es la línea predominante
no dentro de el pluralismo que existe
dentro de un sistema que combina la
pluralidad y la competencia política
ideológica y a la vez el respeto a la
línea ideológica musulmana establecida
en la constitución de 1979 salida de la
revolución islámica iraní no
líder del país tendrá como principales
retos levantar la economía completamente
diezmada por las sanciones
internacionales y darle un rumbo al
acuerdo nuclear de 2015 como se ve el
panorama con los candidatos que están en
contienda
mire aquí parece ser que había una
dificultad política entre la línea del
presidente saliente roja ni y la línea
que marca el líder de la revolución
entonces he escuchado un comentario hoy
desde teherán que señala que lo que va a
ocurrir es una mayor homogeneidad una
mayor cohesión entre luego gobierno sea
cual sea este y el líder de la
revolución de cara a resolver
favorablemente algo muy importante para
el país como es la vuelta a los acuerdos
con los norteamericanos y las potencias
occidentales y dichas del mundo del 2015
y poder reconstruir la economía y
reforzar la relación estrecha que tiene
el país con china y con rusia para
padres como usted bien dice reconstruir
levantar la economía muy afectada por
las sanciones implantadas por la
administración trump desde el 2018 en
que se salió de los acuerdos e
inmediatamente practicó una política de
máxima presión
el país usted justamente estaba
mencionando la difícil situación
económica que atraviesa el país cómo se
le da la vuelta a esta situación
realmente es una alianza con sus con sus
partidarios y el poder adquisitivo de
los iraníes realmente está afectado en
este momento
sabe que el país tiene ese problema la
inflación muy grave los precios vuelan
pero no es la única amenaza tiene
amenaza en las fronteras la guerra del
año pasado entre armenia y azerbaiyán ha
sido un desafío la victoria de los
talibanes en afganistán es un desafío
para el país
israel le amenaza continuamente al país
ha asumido la responsabilidad de
atentados terroristas contra
instalaciones estratégicas del país y el
asesinato de un científico de manera que
hay potencias extranjeras muy
interesadas en desestabilizar el país y
la con las sanciones y la inflación son
consecuencias directas de estas
sanciones que afectan al al valor de la
moneda pero es un país con un bastante
capacidad tecnológica e industrial y es
posible que el escenario que salga vaya
a permitir junto con las esperanzas
puestas en las negociaciones de viena
los conversaciones de viena sin
reconstruir la situación señor ejido
pues muchas gracias por su análisis
estamos muy pendientes de estos
resultados en irán